on anti-fragility and coddling the
american mind if i may read just a few
lines from chief justice john roberts
which i found is really beautiful
so it's not just about viewpoint
diversity but it's real struggle absurd
unfair struggle that seems to be
formative to the human mind he says from
time to time in the years to come
i hope you will be treated unfairly
so that you will come to know the value
of justice i hope that you will suffer
betrayal because that will teach you the
importance of loyalty sorry to say but i
hope you will be lonely from time to
time so that you don't take friends for
granted i wish you bad luck again from
time to time so that you will be
conscious of the role of chance in life
and understand that your success is not
completely deserved and that the failure
of others is not completely deserved
either
and when you lose as you will from time
to time i hope every now and then your
opponent will gloat over your failure it
is a way for you to understand the
importance of sportsmanship i hope
you'll be ignored so you know the
importance of listening to others and i
hope you will have just enough pain to
learn compassion
whether i wish these things are not
they're going to happen
and whether you benefit from them or not
will depend upon your ability to see the
message in your misfortunes
he read that in a middle school
graduation
yes for his sons his son's middle school
graduation
that's what i was trying to say only
that's much more beautiful yeah and uh i
think your work is really important and
it is beautiful and it's bold and
fearless and it's a huge honor to sit
with me i'm a big fan thank you for
spending your valuable time with me
today john thank you so much thanks so
much lex what a pleasure
you